de la 10e à la 11e circonscription des
yvelines où une législative partielle
est programmé élection rendue nécessaire
après la démission de nadia qui est
entrée au gouvernement
premier tour le dimanche 20 septembre
éventuel deuxième tour le dimanche 27
septembre
onze candidats sont en lice pour ce
scrutin les noms peut-être qu'ils vont
s'afficher dans un instant pour cette
11e circonscription avec moi en plateau
en tout cas thibault langlois bonsoir
bonsoir mais ce canal vous êtes le
candidat suppléant de valérie froberger
vous êtes vous pour la france insoumise
valérie offre aux bergers du parti
communiste français puisque les deux
formations ont choisi de s'unir pour le
scrutin dans la 11e circonscription déjà
pourquoi cette candidature et pourquoi
partent sur une autre pour le pour
l'élection pourquoi cette candidature et
bien je pense qu'on peut faire le
constat que la situation économique du
pays est assez est assez désastreuse
on savait déjà que notre système
fonctionne et mal avec la crise
sanitaire
c'est devenu particulièrement évident
avec les suppressions d'emplois qui se
multiplient et nous pensons que la
réponse du président de la république
n'est pas la bonne
on l'a vu sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire a été assez erratique assez
autoritaire aussi à présent le plan
d'investissement qui est proposée qui
est certes conséquent se contentent de
distribuer des aides
certes massive à des entreprises qui
continuait en même temps de licenciés de
polluer voir les 2 dont on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler juste après et
pourquoi parler partir pardon unis dans
cette élection avec le parti communiste
en synchronisé le parti communiste
français nous avons nous avons à coeur
tous les 2 2
de défendre l'humain d'abord de
véritablement investir dans dans la vie
des gens dont social dans l'écologie
proposer une véritable alternative à la
présidence macron donc nous avions de
véritable convergence de vues et c'est
ce qui a amené cette candidature au tour
de valérie froberger qui est aide
soignante et nous pensons que elle
représente bien les gens qui travaillent
les gens qui ont été en première ligne
pendant cette crise et qui valérie qui
portera une voie écologique démocratique
populaire à l'assemblée nationale alors
il n'y aura pas pour autant une union
des gauches union totale dé gauche
puisque la concert régional et premier
adjoint de la mairie de trappes sandrine
dans gangs se présente également une
candidature sous la bannière de
génération avec un soutien d'europe
écologie les verts cette union plus
large n'était pas possible à ce que des
discussions ont eu lieu pour un éventuel
rassemblement des discussions auront
éventuelle d'un compte évidemment eu
lieu cependant nous avons appris la
déclaration de candidature de son nom
gambe alors que celle ci était toujours
était toujours en cours nous avons
appris par votre presse donc nous en
avons pris acte voilà pour le fond pour
la forme et pour le fond c'est vrai
qu'il y avait
certaines inconnues sur la candidature
de madame grand bond par exemple le
groupe qu'elle rejoindrait à l'assemblée
nationale les positions qu'elle allait
défendre on ne savait pas trop s'il
allait les rejoindre un groupe comme au
ps qui a voté non certains membres ont
voté la confiance au gouvernement
successifs voir un groupe de ma
chronique de gauche si tenté que ça
existe et est ce que la porte est
totalement fermé ou un éventuel
éventuelle qualification au second tour
pourrait amener à rediscuter un nouveau
dans ma foi on verra en fonction des
détails rapport de force mais je pense
vraiment que nous avons des chances
d'aller au second tour est de
représenter
voilà de représenter véritablement la
force de l'opposition populaire alors
permis de vous aider celles que vous
avez envie de porter à l'assemblée
nationale vous parliez tout à l'heure ce
plan de relance de 100 milliards d'euros
qui a été annoncé par le gouvernement
35 milliards d'euros seront dédiés aux
entreprises et les tpe et pme ça ça a
été annoncé vont avoir des impôts réduit
ça c'est pas suffisant il fallait aller
plus loin selon vous le problème c'est
que par exemple vous avez ddm ma psy qui
ont été attribués à des entreprises
comme airbus comme air france comme
compte-t-elle si je crois des
entreprises qui pour autant ne sont pas
tenus de préserver l'emploi ou
d'investir massivement dans l'écologie
c'est vraiment des aides qui sont
distribués sans la préparation sans
véritable planification d'ailleurs cette
nomination de françois bayrou au poste
de commissaire est le commissaire au
plan au commissaire au plan et
tassé en effet d'annonce même cédé
commencement qui eux aussi l'économie
française au tir aussi l'économie
française mais qui avant d'être pris
dans les mailles du réchauffement
climatique et qui vont devoir s'adapter
alors ce travail d'adaptation n'est pas
fait du tout ce que nous proposons nous
c'est d'inciter justement les
entreprises qui reçoivent d'obliger les
entreprises qui reçoivent des aides à
investir en faveur de pour les énergies
décarbonées pour les mobilités douces et
surtout de maintenir l'emploi dont la
majorité n'ont concitoyens qui sont
scénaristes travaillent ont besoin
d'ailleurs il faut aussi mettre l'accent
sur l'aide aux tpe pme aux petites
entreprises qui sont dans une situation
extrêmement difficile en ce moment un
mot d'un autre axe que vous aurez sans
doute l'occasion de développer au cours
d'un débat c'est de la gratuité du port
du masque un la gratuité des masques
pour tout ça ça a été tranchée par le
gouvernement il y aura pas de gratuité
pour les français vous souhaitez la
gratuité c'est une très mauvaise chose
parce que sur ceux sur ce plan de ce
plan de relance de 100 milliards on
aurait quand même pu mettre quelque
argent de côté pour soulager un peu les
familles modestes et retraités
ces familles sur lesquels ce budget
masse que peu pesé de manière assez
conséquent ça peut monter à 100 euros
plus on aura l'occasion de développer un
peu plus les thématiques 1 au cours d'un
débat auquel participeront les candidats
de cette 11e circonscription dans cette
11e circonscription des yvelines merci
thibault langlois d'être venu en plateau
je rappelle que vous êtes le candidat
suppléante valérie froberger pour cette
candidature commune je le rappelle entre
la france insoumise et le parti
communiste français
juste avant de rendre l'antenne un autre
candidat jérémy bizet pour france
écologie sera en campagne sur le terrain
samedi matin à lui et son équipe seront
présents sur le marché de saint cyr
l'école c'est à partir de 10h30